what's the meaning of this strange signal when
is it difficult to get a message delivered how
do industrial people keep in touch with each other
how to attract attention in an auto assembly plant
when you need more right-hand doors make this side
and in a few minutes along come the needed doors
more headlights here's the signal for those
in a big 44-acre factory like this even sign
language plays a part in keeping efficiency
high and costs down and lower costs mean the
higher wages can be paid without raising
prices to the consumer communications in
the factory is a problem that's being met
by alert industrialists in a wide variety
of ways for example a cleveland machine parts
manufacturer installed a radio station right
in the factory to speed the flow of information
back and forth between executives supervisory
personnel and employees a flow that is essential
to the successful functioning of any industrial
team this control room is the nerve center of
a miniature radio broadcasting system that's
in constant touch with everything that goes on
anywhere in the huge plant roving through the
company's 25 scattered departments are men
with walkie talkies stoppages of production
can be costly to the employees the company
and the nation because only by keeping the
wheels turning can we produce the things
we need to improve the American standard
of living and provide for the National Defense
trouble is quickly reported to the control room
from the control room the report is
relayed directly to one of the 84
departments or executive offices that
might be concerned with the trouble
some companies now even use television to
promote teamwork and improve efficiency here
at a California electronics company a closed
circuit TV system from its company officials
to make announcements tell about company plans or
new products and generally tie the several hundred
persons employed here into a more closely knit
industrial family there's a program every noon
hour that includes interviews with interesting
visitors employees have a phone number to call
to pose questions to the visitor or to the
boss a big Michigan firm uses television even
more spectacularly in spreading word about new
products to employees in all parts of the country
a big showing of the new products complete with
entertainment is staged here in Flint and while
local people are being entertained and informed
in person many thousands of others are getting
the news simultaneous laya theaters in key cities
all over the country in 50 big population centers
large crowds catch every word every note of
music every gleam of light reflected off the
new products the far-flung corporation is brought
together into a tightly knit group unified by good
company communications company officials can talk
to many thousands of their associates at one time
radio-television now motion pictures are
widely used - and imparting to personnel
the information it must have to carry on as it
should by means of training films new employees
find out about company policies and practices
acquiring in minutes an understanding that might
come only after many months if they depended on
scuttlebutt or the grapevine however one firm
New Jersey's Atlantic City Electric Company
established an official grapevine it put in a
recording device that allows company officials
to give out quickly and easily the latest news
about the firm and its employees and any other
information that should be distributed rapidly
and accurately now anyone in the plant simply by
picking up the telephone and dialing to 7/7 can
get a pre-recorded full of the bulletins cover
every imaginable subject but all have to do with
supplying employees with information they need in
order to remain well-informed effective members of
the team whatever the announcement by this method
they get the news fast and they get it straight
the old-fashioned bulletin board of course
will never completely disappear although
its importance is often diminished by the 20th
century improvements on it that we have just seen
the bulletin board liked the reading rack which
carries more detailed information suitable for
leisurely study at home is a means of conveying
information for management to employees but it's
equally important for employees to be able
to communicate with management a widely used
device is the suggestion box which makes possible
communication in the other direction upward toward
the people with overall responsibility whether
it's an actual suggestion box or an individual who
serves as a walking receptacle of new ideas the
flow of information upward is fully as important
as the flow in the other direction in fact that's
what industrial communications are all about
making sure that ideas flow in both directions
to everybody's benefit here for example we see
a group of Baltimore workers who make up a junior
Board of Directors their recommendations to the
senior board of directors are rarely turned down
in a company that feels like most others that the
interests of employees stockholders management
and the public are one and the same thing
at a railroad shop in Huntington West
Virginia for instance as their company
prepared to build a new maintenance shop see
and our employees got together during lunch
periods and after hours to discuss
what a railroad shop should be like
one thing they decided was that the wheel shop had
to be closer to the center of things soul wheels
wouldn't have to be trundled half a mile to where
they were needed there were a lot of suggestions
like that many of which were incorporated into a
15 by 17 foot model the men put together on their
own needless to say management was delighted by
the spontaneous demonstration of company spirit
at the Grayson controls division of the
Robert Shaw Fulton controls company in Long
Beach California the matter of communications
between all levels of the organization is given
the most serious consideration here we see
a meeting in progress at which an executive
briefs foreman on company plans for the future
these are the supervisors of the plants working
force the people who come into constant direct
contact with the men and women who turn out the
company's products to most employees the foreman
is management to top executives he is the key man
who serves as the chief communicator of vital
information in both directions and since the
big job of those executives is to make things
happen that otherwise would not happen and since
communications as a means of accomplishing this
their dependence on the foreman is considerable
consequently frequent even daily briefing
sessions are common throughout industry
here the communications link is closed as
supervisor and employee exchange information
or opinions occasionally as now top management
participates directly in the exchange although
in a large company employing thousands
such direct participation is less frequent
the interview in progress here is for
the purpose of gathering information
for the plant magazine another means of
communication in which this company excels
the reporter gets a laugh and an item that's
likely to put this employee's name in print
actually the women normally work almost
side-by-side the news gatherer being among
the magazine's sparetime department correspondents
bigger stories are handled personally by editor
Joe Macmillan who's often accompanied by a
photographer these men are among the many
who staff thousands of employee publications
throughout American industry some playing some
fancy the periodicals are designed to make
sure that all employees receive all the news
that affects the welfare of their companies and
thus their own welfare and that of their families
now let's get back to the department correspondent
we met earlier while her news items are still
fresh and timely they're collected by the
editor himself with the deadline for the
next issue fast approaching he may have a
question or two of his own a fact or a date
to be checked everybody wants his name in the
magazine but not if it's going to be misspelled
back in the office the editor and artist
William Miller concentrate next on one of
the spectacular covers that make their magazine
famous among industrial journalists everywhere
it's the rule in this office to pay
special attention to the covers to
make them as eye-catching as attractive
as possible so that the reader will want
to find out more inside employee publications
like newspapers and magazines of other kinds
must be read to be worthwhile unless
the information is presented in an
interesting manner gaining a wide audience
the whole operation can be a costly waste
and now it's time for a last-minute check with
higher authority though procedure will vary with
the organizational structure used by individual
companies it's the public relations department
that's responsible for this magazine so the
relief valve as the publication is called gets
a thorough going-over before it's passed along
to the printer again there's special attention
to the matter of the cover which often has
gained its impact from the way in which
it makes use of moveable dials cutouts pull
outs and many other attention-getting devices
some back issues serve to illustrate the point a
wheel of fortune is a forceful reminder of a high
standard of living enjoyed by industrial workers
an official message from management was presented
in this fashion who could resist pulling it out
to read and so they go examples of the way the
editors of company publications all over the
country are seeking to bring to their readers
facts bearing on the operation of our economy
such matters as inflation and how it affects
everyone and what causes it in homes across the
nation it is important for people to know that
wasteful government spending harms everyone that
tax burdens that are too heavy hamper the ability
of people to save and invest and prevent business
from growing as fast as it could and providing
more and better jobs company publications let
families like this know that management and labor
by working together and cooperating to prevent
waste and produce more efficiently can provide
more of the good things of life for everyone
and assure American preeminence in the world